طب تم طابتها اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى
بانوراما وهذه عناوينها
يقترح على تاسيس اليه سوريا اليه سوريا
ثلاثيه دمشق التي لم ترد الى الان لماذا
تتباطئ دمشق رغم الحماس التركيه والمباركه
الروسيه
مقتل جندي حفظ السلام الايرلندي في لبنان
حادث عربي ام تفلت امني بسبب فوضى سلاح
بعد عرضها للمسلسل
هل يتدرك اعطال الاسره المالكي الموقف
الخلافي المتكرر عبر التاريخ ام تعمقه
منصه الترفيه العملاقه نتفليكس
انها لتثبت انها الاقوى اثرا من المسرح
والصحافه مقارنه بالماضي
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله
ترحيبنا روسيه بدعوه انقره الانديه ثلاثيه
للدبلوماسيه مع سوريا وكاله سبورت نقل
الانباء نقلت عن وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
قولها ان موسكو تجري الاتصالات مع دمشق
بشان اقتراح الرئيس التركي اردوغان عقد
لقاء يضم الرئيسين السوري بشار الاسد
والروسيه
يضم زعيمي البلدين اضافه الى سوريا مشيرا
الى ان الرئيس الروسيه قابل هذا العرض
بايجابيه بالمقابل ذكر وكاله ريان
وباريستي للانباء ان موقف سوريا من الفكره
لم يعرف بعد لكن موسكو على اتصال في
مسؤولينا في دمشق
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول طه عوده المحلل
السياسي ومن دمشق عبد الحميد توفيق الكاتب
الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بكما يعني بدايه حول
هذه الاليه المزرعه عقدها او اللقاءات
المزرعه عقدها بدايه ليتوجه الى الى
اسطنبول
او الحماس التركي لعقد هذا اللقاء في هذا
الوقت تحديدا بعد ان كان الرئيس اردوغان
قال بان ما بعد الانتخابات قد تعود
العلاقه مع دمشق
نعم تحياتي لك في البدايه استاذ عادل
وضيفك الكريم والاستدع المشاهدين هناك
تطورات حصلت خلال الايام الاخيره الماضيه
تتذكر قبل اسبوعين من الان كان هناك
مشاورات روسيه تركيه في مدينه اسطنبول
وخرج بمقترح تركي فيما يتعلق بالعمليه
العسكريه البريه لم تصال هناك اي تفاصيل
بكامل حول هذه المحادثات ولكن يبدو ان
تركيا هناك اقرب كثيره الى روسيا ثم يتعلق
بموضوع العمليه العسكريه او التفاهمات ما
يتعلق بابعاد الوحدات الكرديه عن حدودها
نعم كان هناك خلال الشهرين الماضيه كانت
رغبه تركيه حتى وصل الامر هناك يكون اتصال
ما بين ارغان والاسد لكن رفض الاسد او
النظام السوري لموضوع همم يعني التركي او
التطبيع مع تركيا من اجل عدم همم توفير
ورقه انتخابيه لرئيس اردوغان هي بطات هذا
الامر هناك نقطه اخرى متعلقه انا تصوري
متعلقه بالتطبيق او بالتقارب التركي عفوا
التقارب التركي الروسي وخاصه في الملف
السوري يبدو انه هناك تركيا تحاول قدر
الامكان قبيله موعد الانتخابات انهاء هذا
الملف اقصد التقارب مع سوريا هذا هناك لا
يجب علينا نسال هناك مسار اخر يعني همم
تركته انقره تقريبا قبل عام ونصف من الان
وهو مسار التصالح مع عدد كبير من الدول
العربيه وكان اخرها مع اسرائيل وحتى وسط
الامور الى مرحله متقدمه بعد المصافحه
التاريخيه ما بين الرئيس اردوغان هو
السيسي اليسا اعتقد انقر حاليا تحاول قد
الامكان انهاء هذا الملف
بالدرجه الاولى يخدم همم داخل التركي
وايضا قطع الطريق على المعارضه التركيه
التي كانت دائما تنوع بورقه اللاجئين ورقه
سوريا الى دمشق معي من هناك عبد الحميد
توفيق الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بك سيد اا عبد
الحميد يعني في حماسه تركيه ولكن في عدم
اكتراث او ع- لنقل تباطؤ في قبول هذه
الدعوه من دمشق هل هي بالفعل لعدم توفير
هذه الورقه او الدعايه المجانيه لي
اردوغان لتكون ضمن ملفه الانتخابي
المشاهدين
اعتقد ان هذه هي النقطه من النقاط التي
يمكن ان تعمل عليها الدبلوماسيه السوريه
في تعاطيها مع ما يمكن تسميته هجوم
المصالحه التركيه على دمشق هذا الهجوم
الدبلوماسيه التي طوره اردوغان منذ لحظه
تفجير قنبله الاولى بانه على استعداد
لقياده الصفحه وللقاء الرئيس السوري بعد
كل الذي جرى بينهما على المستويين الشخصي
وعلى مستوى الدول اعتقد بان هذه الحكايه
الداخليه التركيه هي جزء محوري محرض لما
يسعى اليه اردوغان ولكن همم اقتراح العمل
اللي هي الثلاثيه لتكون هناك لقاء قمه
ثلاثي يبدو انه همم خرج من الاردوغان لكي
يعطي انطباعا جديا بانه ينوي ذلك مع كل
هذه ال- ال- ال- ال- المعطيات التي تشهدها
من الجانب التركي تبدو دمشق وكانها تنتظر
او تراقب او تصمت انا لا اعتقد بانها الان
هي تماطل او همم تواري نفسها بالعكس لان
تصدر موقفا ولديها حساباتها الاكيده هناك
قضايا ومعطيات واقعيه مع الجانب التركي
تتعلق لا تتعلق فقط بالمسائل الشخصيه او
الثنائيه او التجاريه هناك مسائل ذات اربع
سيادي هناك مساء الغاء طبع عمدا همم هناك
احتلال تركي لاراضي شاسعه همم ويبدو ان
الجانب السوري ينظر الى هذه الاندفاعات
التركيه بكثير من التروي وربما في حساباته
على ما اعتقد انه لا يريد ان يعطي هذه في
هذه الفتره
ايحاء بان اردوغان سيقطف ثمرتا من ثمار
الملف السوري الذي تعتبره سوريا قد هو
الذي زرع كل ال- ال- المعوقات والتعقيدات
فيه على كل المستويات العسكريه والسياسيه
والامنيه اعتقد سوريا رغم كل الصعوبات
التي تعيش هات سياديا دبلوماسيا اقتصاديا
معيشيا لا يعني ان قياده الدوله لا تدخروا
كثيرا من الاساليب والطرق الدبلوماسيه
التي يمكن لها ان تتعاطى مع هذا الامر رغم
وجود العمل الروسي
الذي يكون مؤثرا الى حد ما في هذا هذا
السؤال حتى في في التدخل الروسي او الضغط
الروسي على دمشق بان تذهب الى الى ما
يريده اردوغان وبالتالي على الاقل التقارب
هذا يحدث حاليا قبل الانتخابات
انا اعتقد بان الضغط الروسي اذا ما مرسى
على دمشق سيكون هناك لدمشق خيارات اخرى
يمكن لها ان تقوم بعمل مثل اولا عمليه
التسويف والمماطله في اعداد الملفات من
خلال التشدد في مطالبها المحقه اولا
انسحاب الجيش التركي من الاراضي التي
يحتلها في الشمال السوري ثانيا تفكيز جبهه
النصره او هيئه تحرير الشام التي تسيطر
على اقسام واسعه من ادلب ثالثا تفكيك
المعارضه المسلحه المسمى بالجيش الوطني
وهو لا يعودون بعشرات الالاف اعتقد بان
اعباء ربما تستطيع دمشق ان تدرج كل هذه
المطالب ضمن خصوصياتها وضمن الدبلوماسيتها
حتى امام الروس ان لم تكن قادره على
الحصول على مثل هذه الضمانات الاكيده انا
اعتقد بان الامر سيكون همم صراعا
دبلوماسيا ليس سهلا سيد همم سيد طه هل
اليوم همم اسطنبول قادره على اعطاء هذه
هاتي الى دمشق وبالتالي الجيش الوطني
النصره كما اشار ضيفي من دمشق هذه كلها
مخاوف سوري هل تستطيع اسطنبول تم انا
الدمشق حول ذلك ومن ثم بدا صفحه العلاقه
يعني انا تصور اعتقد الموضوع هو ليس
بالامر السيل هو الموضوع شائك للغايه ولكن
اذا تابعنا الاشهر الاخيره الماضيه كان
هناك قاسم مشترك ما بين انقره ودمشق ان
عمليه التطبيع هي ركزت على مفهوم وهم
مفهوم مكافحه الارهاب مكافحه الارهاب وجهه
النظر تركيا او حسب مفهوم التركي هو همم
موضوع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وهذا ما يهم
تركيا بالدرجه الاولى وخاصه هذه الوحدات
تركيا حاليا منذ فتره تتحادت وت- هناك
محادثات همم مستمره مع همم الرؤوس واعتقد
وصلوا الى صيغه مشتركه حول هذه القضيه
وخاصه فيما يتعلق به هناك ابعاد الوحدات
الكليه عن حدودها هذا ما يهم تركيا
بالدرجه الاولى هو ال- الحدود اعتقد
الامور الاخرى انا تصور ليست في ليله
وضحاها ممكن حالها الامور صعبه عليها
الى الى ما يفعلها اردوغان من هذه العمليه
لا يستقيم الامر
يعني انا يعني اعتقد يعني موضوع يعني حلقه
المشكله وخروج القوات التركيه اعتقد هذا
ليس بالامر السان نتحدث انه هناك مسار
الستان السوتشي ما بين انقره وموسكو وحتى
طاهران وهذا منذ تقريبا عام 2018 انقره هي
همم هناك تتقارب وتتحدث مع الروس روسيا
حاليا هي بحاجه ماسه لتركيا في هذا الوقت
الذي تمر به الوضع المتازم على الساحه
الاوكرانيه واقصر في اطار همم الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه لذا اعتقد ان حاليا
اذا تحدثت
همم المسار فيما يتعلق الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان وضعه هناك استراتيجيه لهذا المسار
وهو في بيتعلق بلقاءات على مستوى
الاستخبارات الدفاع وزراء الخارجيه ومن ثم
يكون وزراء على الرؤساء واعتقد روس يترقد
هذا الاقتراح بشكل سريع رغم ان روسيا خلال
الفتره الاخيره الماضي حصل خلال الماضيه
كانت مطباتها كانت تريد فقط الوساط ولكن
جديد المره هذه ان تلعب هي دور كبير في
هذا الملف وتسحب الورقه يعني من يعني همم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي كانت
تحاول قدر الامكان الضغط على روسيا في
ساحه اخرى سيد عبد الحميد اليوم همم هذا
هذه العوده الى العلاقات ما بين دمشق
واسطنبول همم
تكون صلبه حتى يبنى عليها مستقبلنا اما ان
ذلك همم فقط تحالف مرحاليه
[موسيقى]
على كل صعد بين سوريا وصلت المرحله في تلك
الايام الى الغاء التاشيرات بين البلدين
ورفع الحواجز على الحدوديه وبات المواطن
السوري يدخل الى تركيا بهويته والتركيا
لا بالضبط اليوم هناك معطيات حقيقيه هناك
حرب دارت عشر سنوات طحنت الاخضر واليابس
وسوريه
[موسيقى]
على على بعضهم وبالتالي اعتقد ان المعطيات
القائمه اليوم كما تفضل ضيفك من اسطنبول
الامر معقد جدا 22.000 كيلو متر مربع
تقريبا تركيا في الشمال السوري هل تستطيع
القياده السوريه ان تقول اهلا بك يا
اردوغان وهو يحتل هذه الارض لا يعتق ذلك
هذا اولا ثانيا هل تعتقد همم دمشق بان او
بتاع العفن تعتقد موسكو بان دمشق تقول نعم
على الرحب والسعه بدون اي همم
مبادرات حقيقيه من الجانب التركي وبالضمان
الروسي اعتقد ان هناك اوراق
وامنيه وعسكريه بيد الجانب السوري رغم
الحال الصعب الذي تعيشه منها على سبيل
المثال ما يتعلق بال الجانب همم الامني
المتعلق بالقلق والهوايش التركيه من من
قوى القوى الكرديه وتحديدا همم يد حزب
العمال الكردستاني في شرق الفرات وشرق
الفرات يعني ذلك همم الان همم يبطئ عمليه
التجاره الداخليه وتجاره المعابر عوده
السوريه اعتقد او دمشق اعتقد بانها لديها
الاستعداد في همم ادارتها للصراع
الدبلوماسي المقبل مع الجانب التركي
بالوجود الروسي
لانها ستكون اكثر ميلا للتفاهم معه القوى
الكرديه لكي تعزز اوراقها في الضغط على
جانب التركي في هذا الاطار نعم سيد طه
دمشق اقرب الى همم الكرد منها الى انقره
كيف تنظر الى ذلك
توافق على ما قاله ضيفي من دمشق
لا انا انا انا لا اعتقد ذلك حاليا تتذكر
يعني تركيا وخاصه السابقه كانت تتحدث يعني
كان هل ممكن اعاده قوات النظام الى الحدود
تركيا منذ تقريبا عام قبل ان نتحدث عن
هناك تقارب ما يهم تركيا بالدرجه الاولى
موضوع ابعاد الوحدات الكرديه عن حدوديه
ولكن اتصور اعتقد المفاوضات وهي مستمره
نزل وحمايه تقريبا هي مع الرصوص وصلت الى
مرحله همم متقدمه وحاليا عندما يتحدث
الرئيس اردوغان عن مقترح هناك قمه ثلاثيه
انا تصور اعتقد الامر شبه منتهي واعتقد
يمكن ان نرى الامور في همم شهر او شهرين
ان يكون الاكل زعماء الثلاثه خلال المرحله
المقبله وخاصه ان روسيا حاليا هي بحاجه
ماسه ان احنا نتحدث عن الوضع شاتك قبل
قليل في اوكرانيا وصل الى مرحله خطيره
متقدمه جدا كانت تعلم سوا روسيا الدول
الاوروبيه
تريد ان تحدد تحذر مكسب في ساحات اخرى
ممكن هذا يكون على الساحه السوريه طيب
السيد طه عوده اوغلو المحلل السياسي من
اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا لك الشكر موصول الى
السيد عبد الحميد توفيق الكاتب الصحفي من
دمشق
استمرون معكم
بعد الفاصل
مقتله جنديه حفظ السلام الايرلندي في
لبنان حادث عربي ام تفلت امني بسبب فوضى
السلاح